foreign
looking good
oh what a day what a day Dwight are you
carrying a gun The holster was a gift
from my great uncle honk um I don't know
I guess he's saying that he's proud of
me Dwight guns make me really
uncomfortable the gun is just an
accessory to the holster okay I can't
walk around wearing an empty holster why
do you need to wear the holster at all
why do you need to keep wearing those
booby shirts all the time thank you
put your cell phone in it instead
hello
you could put a banana in it why would I
put a banana in my holster in case you
weren't hungry now but you got hungry
later Dwight no gun okay don't make us
call Joe okay all right fine everyone
calm down
someone get me a banana sorry I freaked
you guys out
it's so loud
whoa
do your worst
[Music]
uh you can keep your pants on actually
if you just drop them down a bit that'd
be great they're already off my good sir
I really prefer they not be down well I
think Down's better sweating pretty
heavily down there
do you think you could work from this we
made some small adjustments okay you
want me just a few adjustments yeah
all right let's begin this is where I
grinning that was just a cotton swab
invest in softer cotton sir
oh
[Applause]
obviously you can go the ass tattoo
route and obviously I'm gonna like it
[Applause]
why didn't I choose Andy to run the
office
because he's all surface uncomplicated
what you see is what you get
could be a recipe for mediocrity yes but
then again it might just be why people
fight for him
it's a nard dog
the Mickey name
oh fire oh my goodness what's the
procedure what do we do people oh how
did that happen it's out in the hall no
we don't know that the smoke could be
coming through an air duct oh my God
okay it's happening everybody stay calm
thank you everyone what's the procedure
calm down no no Michael no touch the
handle if it's hot there could be a fire
in the hallway
[Music]
Phyllis people human lives however can
ah my hand that's hot this one's hot too
okay we're trapped everyone for himself
have you ever seen a burn victim okay
a rag a damp rag perhaps let's remember
those procedures
that's the wrong way we've already tried
that remember your exit points exit
points people what's next stay alive I'm
getting help pull me up you're too heavy
I only weigh 82 pounds
how about 9-1-1 anyone 9-1-1
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay I am not dying come on
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
attention
employees of Dunder Mifflin this has
been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training exercise
so what have we learned
oh come on it's not real Stanley no no
no no no no you will not die Stanley
Stanley you will not die Stanley Stanley
Barack is President you are black
sailing I'm gonna give him out to mouth
no no don't give a mouth to mouth for
this he's gonna swallow this time
leave me alone
okay Jimmy this is for you to show you
that anything is possible fantastic
right yep this is also for the troops
oh
Doctor Is In
[Music]
now what
D'Angelo
oh my God are you all right Michael
Aaron okay will you call 911 please who
should I say is calling Aaron so yeah
three
200 watt 2 bar
so that's it pounds and loud
pal says to bartender house
every time everybody everybody
yes
dress web interesting yeah I get it okay
wolves and stuff has anyone seen Ryan or
Kelly oh yes uh they left together a
little while ago
Kelly was hoping that you would keep the
baby so they can start a new life
together
that's it here
cold child services and report an
abandoned baby we'll find a better
parent than Ryan in no time oh I don't
know
um Kevin
oh I can help you with that yeah I mean
I can find someone who will Who will
love that
beautiful little boy the way he deserves
hey
this is better yes
hey yes it is oh yes it is if Ryan wants
his baby back please tell him where to
find me
we'll be somewhere in Europe
one way